- You know what I need?
A cool nickname, like CNC Music Factory.
No, that's not cool.
Alexandria Ocasio-Cortez has
been a member of Congress
for less than a month.
At this time last year, no
one outside of New York City,
and even lots of people
inside New York City,
had literally never heard of her.
Which is what makes this
fact all the more incredible.
In a late January CNN poll,
almost six in 10 Americans
not only know her name, but
also have an opinion about her.
That opinion is, slightly, negative.
27% of people have a favorable view
of the new New York congresswoman,
while 32% have a negative view.
But that's not the real story.
The real story is that a 29
year old first-time candidate,
who was running as a Democratic Socialist
against the man many saw as a
future Speaker of the House,
has rapidly become one
of the most recognizable
faces in the Democratic Party nationally.
Now think about these numbers.
41% of people say they either
have never heard of AOC
or don't know enough about
her to have an opinion.
In that same CNN poll, 28% of people said
they either hadn't
heard of Mitch McConnell
or didn't know enough about
him to offer an opinion.
Mitch McConnell is the freaking
Senate Majority Leader.
He has been in the Senate since 1984.
If you turn on cable TV for an
hour on any day of the week.
You should do that, by the way.
You have a decent chance of either seeing
or hearing or both McConnell.
And yet, Alexandria Ocasio-Cortez
is within shouting distance
of McConnell when it comes
to how many people know her.
Or, look at this in another way.
Stacey Abrams was one of
the shining Democratic stars
of the 2018 election,
running to be the first African American
female governor in the country.
Abrams came within a hairsbreadth
of winning in the
reddish state of Georgia.
So popular was Abrams
among the Democratic base,
that congressional Democrats asked her
to deliver the Democratic response
to Trump's State of the Union Address.
Given Abram's high profile,
she must be nearly as well-known
as Alexandria Ocasio-Cortez, right?
Wrong!
(buzzer dings)
Sorry, that was a little harsh.
Six in 10 people in the CNN
poll had never heard of Abrams.
Or didn't know enough to
offer an opinion about her.
So, how the heck did
AOC get to this point,
and more importantly,
what will she do now?
Alright, the first question
is easier to answer,
so I'm gonna try and
answer that one first.
Ocasio-Cortez's win over then-congressman,
Joe Crowley, was national news,
and her stunned reaction
to her victory went viral,
which, had it ended there,
would have made a nice story.
But it would not have
turned a freshman member
from a safely Democratic seat in a
largely Democratic state
into a national superstar.
Of course, it didn't end there.
Ocasio-Cortez's victory
became, for liberals,
a rallying point.
A tangible sign that voters
in the Democratic base
weren't just fed up with Republicans,
but also were sick of
lots of their own members
and their own party establishment too.
Crowley was a symbol of the status quo
and compromise driven politics.
AOC was new blood, using
confrontation as political strategy
and saying exactly what she thought,
no matter the supposed
political consequences.
Now, even as AOC was becoming
a hero to the liberalist left,
she was becoming a villain
to conservatives around the country.
Sidebar!
Which came first: the liberal
love or the conservative hate?
Chicken and the egg, my dude.
For conservatives, Ocasio-Cortez's
unapologetic embrace
of democratic socialism,
her support for hugely high
tax rates on the very wealthy,
and her backing of medicare for all,
made her the poster child for what
they believe the disastrous
future Democrats want.
Now, that Ocasio-Cortez was,
and is, in her 20s, is a Latina,
and maintains a hugely active social media
presence all served to
further fuel the fires
on the left and the right about her.
And yet, here we are.
A 29 year old freshman member
of Congress known by 60%
of the total population with very strong
views held about her on both
sides of the political aisle.
Okay, so now for the tougher question.
What does AOC do next?
It's actually easier to answer what
she probably won't do next.
She's very, very unlikely
to moderate her views
or worry too much about the fact that
she has become the latest
Republican boogeywoman.
She's also not going to
play the traditional role
of a newly elected member of Congress.
Sort of sit and watch while
the more experienced members,
you know, handle things.
After Ocasio-Cortez's election,
and even before she
took the oath of office,
she participated in a sit in
at Nancy Pelosi's office aimed
at convincing the Speaker to
take action on climate change.
Not exactly shining and retiring move.
Ocasio-Cortez has also
drawn considerable attention
for her promotion of what
she calls a Green New Deal,
which she is promised will
be quote, "national, social,
"industrial and economic mobilization at a
"scale not seen since
World War II," end quote.
Now she's expected to introduce that
legislation in the House in mid-February.
Already some Democrats are talking about
Ocasio-Cortez as a potential
presidential candidate.
There's just one problem with that,
she won't be eligible to run
for that for another six years.
You have to be 35.
Now predicting what will happen
six years in the future is a
fool's errand and I am no fool.
At least not today.
And that is the point.
We do this every week twice.
Check back every Tuesday and
Thursday for new episodes.